[Applauso]
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi fanno una
merda c'è il piatto disperato nel
frattempo sotto perché sa che cosa sto
per fare anche le una sensibilità gli
abomini e gli unici di culinari per
quanto mi riguarda è peggio della pizza
collana è peggio della carbonara no si
posizionano oggi facciamo una pizza ma
al posto della base
utilizzeremo un'anguria ci mettiamo al
lavoro ma per prima cosa come sempre
passiamo agli ingredienti per far
stabilizzate merda avremo bisogno di
passata di pomodoro mozzarella per pizza
salamino piccante e una memoria perché
abbiamo deciso di fare questa cosa non
lo so io mi sento veramente in
difficoltà ogni volta che arriva a
luglio ci troviamo sempre a mente questo
bug cioè ci vengono in mente delle idee
e poi dice vabbè ma solo un pochino
troppo calde per l'estate anzi noi
questa ricetta e invernale invernale
quell'altro invernale quindi passiamo da
insalata di riso e che cazzo ci fai con
l'insalata parte mi fa cagare l'insalata
di riso mangia passo a chi piace
insalata di riso a me attenti a voi
piace l'insalata di riso a parlare dice
vanno a copia così sono sempre più
quegli anni di genova testa recaro
ovunque dicevo dipende da come la fai
certamente è un arbin a i pomodorini
carotine che vorrei fondarle in faccia a
chi la prepara a 3000 light faremo
l'insalata di riso ecco mettete un
pollice in giù per perché abbiamo deciso
di fare questa pizza quelli di ammazzare
star lamenta bellezza del viso e poi per
questa pizza de merda tendenzialmente
ogni volta che vediamo un qualcosa anche
è brutto ma allo stesso tempo a quel
tipo quando guarda di cani che fanno la
cacca che tendenzialmente non è un bello
spettacolo ma non riesce a non guardarli
si sta liberando bravo ragazzo enorme
devo riuscire a farla stare qua dente
l'abbiamo guardate il motorino hanno
fermato al senato come un maschietto
mi raccomando lo spessore non ti vedo
bravissimo anche un coltello di 12 cm x
un'anguria è 24 cucina buttato è
diventata masterchef con enrico voglio
provare a fare anche un'altra fetta che
prova a fare un pochino più dritta ok ho
fallito
[Risate]
accendiamo i fuochi avete presente
l'ananas 8 è una merda non giudichiamo
prima di assaggiare posso dire mila
soddisfazione dunque posso di narcan
altra cosa a me dà molta soddisfazione
come sta avvenendo la cucina di cucina è
buttata tra parentesi non so se avete
notato che ho tolto le ditate dalle ante
perché nell'ultimo video c'erano gli fa
schifo sa un po di crepe ma a bordo o no
ragazzi sa tantissimo di creazione della
gianluigi del secondo annusa un senso ma
c'ero c'è più troppo caldo cucinare ma
se devo dire che una ricetta estiva è
un'altra forte dal 20 st diciamo da
mezzo stomaco e la ricetta da stiva che
ve ne pare
oddio bravo ma se un cuoco perché è una
sauna io sto qui davanti con questi le
mani dentro l'anguria guarda
garantirà con gli strumenti no no la
spallata non si può di lara il santo non
si può fare qui c è vero non si può fare
non lo farò
l'anguria che esplode cim i polsi anzi
se abbiamo una clip dell'esperto
gianluigi potremmo metterla il saldo
[Applauso]
a mag hamburger travan tesi gran ricetta
hai visto proprio la divisione
dell'hamburger in 2d quel titani
[Applauso]
vattene via
alex per i fiori questa rosola sono
fallito forse dovremmo girarle lanciarla
verso la società solo per voi una cucina
piatti di merda 2 cucinarlo 40 gradi
fuori 50 dentro io sto morendo buona
senti che l'autore particolari non so
come dire pizza facciamo un salto nel
tempo e arriviamo al momento nel quale
la luce si spenga niente
e questa sarà già pronta la ri a tra
poco perfetto ragazzi allora un calo tra
parlando c'è stato un punto in poi ci
siamo detti forse dovremmo aspettare ci
siamo risposti ma un video si può essere
rovinato ancora di più non credo quindi
se sentirete un trapano vi chiediamo
scusa ti promettiamo che nel nuovo set
non ci saranno trapani se non quel
manigoldo linea fratello enrico
detto ciò posso dire nella salsa
dirigerà soli in generale o con vostra
mamma con mostro a paolo chiunque volete
con un vostro parente un vostro non
parente i fogli di carta da forno già
tagliata sono una cosa che vi svolterà
di più la vita nella vita dobbiamo
lasciare un link in descrizione che
buono questo colore vado a tagliare la
mozzarella la tipologia della pizza
fatta nel video una diavola molto buono
ma diavola cui piace è la mia preferita
e ogni volta che lo facciamo solo test
fateci sapere come la nostra pizza
preferita e soprattutto a quanti di voi
piace la margherita e quanti invece sono
team io che non mi piace
per me la margherita è troppo lei troppo
si riceve troppo normale questa chiamata
bellissimo non è una diavola è stata
nato arrivava al pomodoro che adesso
torna la guida c'era un po di bordino il
cornicione di un po di sale glie lo
metterei tra gari perché sennò c'è il
male condimenti hanno ancora capirà e
salame piccante lo odiavo da ragazzino
crescendo impazzito sottile sottile ma
cavolo questo qui è andato dopo nove
anni a un concerto sono andato a vedere
i fast animals and slow kids a vasca è
un mio amico del cantante concerto
se potete già vedere quando ti svegli
corso dove sei stato colpire vuol dire
anche che me lo volevo tenere un pochino
come ricordo ci sono andato pure con
coming claudio e le orge no le nostre
tipiche orge che si fanno tra amici che
non abbiamo più assaggiarlo un tagliere
le mani di culo nel frattempo ti
inviterei a vedere che cosa sta uscendo
alla pizza un liquame
ma che vuol dire a questo punto
inforniamo tutto ragazzi aspettiamo che
si sciolga tutto perché si sta
ricorrendo a 200 gradi in forno
avrò bomb ci rivediamo qui fra i dieci
minuti vediamo che succede
ok posso dirlo
numeri sì però aspetta che ti metto
subito altro vostro liquame un mondo c'è
in questa pizza chiamare pizza è un
insulto alla pizza puliamo il piatto
come si fa nei ristoranti di cucina
buttata un pochino come facciamo con i
nostri pc dopo aver espletato molto
belle realtà è bella è bella abominevole
sarà abominevole e qui arriviamo al
pezzo che mi fa sbloccare l'assaggio
perché in questi video dovete fanno
tedesca merda che preparano le persone
poi assaggiano felicissime io ero voglio
assaggiare e vedere che cosa il mio
volto il mio stomaco mi suggeriranno di
fare ma era del tutto onesta come sempre
ragazzi e questo momento importante sono
queste le cinque una pizza vera sarebbe
gustosissimo in un boccone con pure
tutto con tutto librai cogese lavoro è
pazzesco dove vi si sta spappolando
segue si sente così forte fa un po
impressione non capire che consistenze
nord in pensavo sarebbe stato molto
molto peggio non è un reale sapore e le
altre tu senti di più sapori buoni in
bocca ma la consapevolezza che quella è
un'anguria è più mentale che palatale mi
disgusta giallo vostro mangiare scaduto
da un mese che manca da solo senza meno
guardare e sopra la mente stessa nello
scambio che a mangiare con una forchetta
bravo così prendi prendiamo non è una
fetta di salame nov un buon bocconi è un
boccone generoso era castissimo e
conflittuale piacermi insieme a ha
ovviamente una cosa che non si fanno
cioè una pizza anguria ragazzi però
superato lo scoglio pizza ma tago
l'anguria diventa piacevole ma riaprendo
un altro bravissimo a combustibile fatto
con un'anguria cotta dove abbiamo
comunque prodotti buoni grazie
all'eccezionale evade il bagnetto della
tua vita nella bella vita che questo è
il tuo boccone remi turno vai vai
mastica veloce concentrati sul salame e
sulla mozzarella aspetta
ma dietro è no le case tutte cazzate
detto merda della miriade di conseguenza
non si fa perché alla morte niente di
più niente di meno dopo la morte se
volete morì
ma dove questa è troppo duro troppo
troppo aspetta una rettifica
effettivamente dopo un po che mai il
sapore si diventa più dei condimenti
però la regale è un atto di fede ragazzi
errico e così abbiati sembra buonissimo
e buonissimo tener buono è certo
trattano aspettano il ppd al costo di
cemento c'è un inizio di morte dove
preferiresti e qualcuno passasse una
botta in testa e in verità non ho finito
e finale chiaramente viene il salame la
mozzarella che per gli amanti diciamo è
una roba molto buona l'anguria viene
meno così spappola e tigra questo fa
questa esclusione di succhi di anguria
non so se l'avete sentito messa acqua da
mozzarella una delle poche esperienze
della vita nella quale tu dici tra
meglio andar meglio andrà meglio
e poi non meglio la prossima volta
quando avrete un'anguria sta arrivando
l'estate potrebbe anche prendermi una su
una fetta una fettina metterla su una
griglia un po di mozzarella un po di
pomodoro un po di sana mino al forno per
sé è una fetta solo 45 minuti e poi se
volete sapere perché non bisogna mai
giudicare rimane aver assaggiato per cui
se assaggerete pagatemi su installeranno
fino ad allora mi mando un bacio grande
iscriviti a questo canale
lasciateci un pollice in su ci vediamo
al prossimo video ciao